This is Radiolab. I'm Robert
Krulwich and Jad Abumrad,
and this hour I'm going to curse you dad.
I'm going to ask you to just
simply do this final thing.
You know that song that we both hate?
Oh, which one? Pump pump, pump pump.
God. It's like the moment you start that
and keep going here, he can. You think
there are some songs that I can stick
in your head and they just won't leave.
There's somebody of course who's head
who got this song somehow stuck in her
head and then his songs that just won't
go away because you didn't even invite
them and they stay. This is an
hour on the music in our heads.
Where does the songs come from?
Why do they stay our whole
hour without Suzanne Vega?
Thankfully on radio lab.
Let me ask you a question that
could get us started here.
When a song gets stuck in your head,
do you even have one in there
right now by any chance? Oliver,
the Broadway show tune of course. What
does it sound like when it's in there?
What does it sound like? Yeah, but
it just think before you answered.
What does it really sound like?
Describe it a musically. Um, well,
it does. Well, it's funny that you
mentioned this. It, it's doesn't actually,
I don't hear any musician because it
loud. No, it's nothing. It's not loud.
It's like a location. No.
Tambour no, it just has a melody.
A vague foggy. Like a shadow
email. Yes, exactly. Okay. Well,
so that's our starting point. You know,
most of us get a song in our head.
It's kind of like what
you described, vague,
but there are people who when they get
songs stuck in our head, it's a whole,
it's a whole different experience.
It is not vague. In fact,
they wish it were vague.
They wish we're a shadow
and you'll know what I mean. In a
second, let me introduce you to someone.
Mary had a little lamb, little lamb.
Little lamb always has songs
running through his head
everywhere that Mary went,
the lamb was sure to go. He's
plagued by them actually.
Then he spoke with our
producer, Lulu Miller.
That was going through your
head just now. That's right.
Mary heard a little loud
over and over again.
Let me have you just introduce
yourself really quick. Oh, I'm uh,
my name is Leo rang girl
and I'm a not young.
I just had my 94th birthday.
I've been in la since I was in
the War World War II as a psychoanalyst.
Oh yeah. I'm still in practice.
We find everything that's been going
on in his own head sort of intriguing,
like from a professional standpoint.
I'm trying to think what
the hell am I doing? Anyway,
this whole thing started
for him about 12 years ago.
He had just had major heart surgery
and he wakes up in his hospital bed.
I wake up in the ICU and almost as soon
as I'm conscious outside my hospital
window, I hear music and there was this,
it sounded few near-real like
hymns. I hear these songs.
I look out the window. I thought,
Geez, a rabbi is out there.
I say to my kids, I casually
say, uh, hey, there's a,
there's a rabbi this singing.
Yeah.
They said, what do you mean? So I said,
there must be as rabbi school and he
must be teaching young people how to be
rabbis. And they, the
kids looked at each other,
the [inaudible]
because they weren't hearing
anything. But at that moment,
that didn't matter to Leo because the
music was so loud and vivid to him.
So totally coming through that window that
I dismissed them as, oh well they
could have their opinion if they want.
I didn't think anything of it.
Uh, Duh, Duh, Duh.
And then the rest of the week
in the hospital, uh, you know,
I'm getting better and better and as I
get better, the music changes, right.
I started being a much
more perky and the songs,
the music out the window changes
to Chattanooga, Choo Choo.
Did Dod do the chat? The new to
Chattanooga Choo Choo did you Julie?
Well, one of the morning, two in the
morning, I'm waking up with these songs
always coming in from right outside
that window. Then I thought,
Jesus isn't pretty energetic
group. They're across the street
at this point.
Leo was beginning to suspect that
something a little weird was going on.
But the real coup,
the grog came when I was
going to leave the hospital.
There were a week or
so and the this tunes,
I didn't know the words at first, but I
started to hear that that Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
Z. Packed up, signed out of the hospital
and got into his car. I was reflecting.
That's when it hit him. I
still was hearing the song.
The song was still coming from outside a
window, but now the scenery was moving.
I thought it was related to the hospital
until the thing across the street.
Here I am in the car
listening to this. Oh,
and that's when the lyrics appear. Yeah.
Finally the words come when
Johnny comes marching home again.
Oh Rah Rah. He couldn't ignore it anymore.
Not only was the song following him
home, it's like the song was about him.
He was the Johnny. The girls
would here with marching home,
coming home from the hospital.
I realized I am listening to me.
I am listening to me.
Okay. Is He really though? I mean,
is he really listening to anything or
is he just think he's hearing something?
Well, there's nothing out there for
him to hear right from the inside.
Like is this brain actually
hearing music? [inaudible]
he for us, there's a professor in
England who had the exact same question.
I called him up.
Hello.
Hi. Can I speak to professor Griffith
please? Okay. Tim Griffith is his name.
He is a professor of cognitive
neurology at New Castle University.
Here's what he did.
He took 35 people who are likely a who
claim to be hallucinating music. Yeah.
And he scanned their brains,
right? Simple experiment.
I just put people on a scan run
and said, what are you hearing now?
What are you hearing now when
they told him, uh, there,
there,
I'm hearing music that that moment he
would snap a picture of their brain,
right? Then he took a different group
of people who have no hallucinations,
played them real music, [inaudible]
music, scan their brains,
and then he compared the pictures.
And if you look,
they look virtually identical.
Know if you would've put those
in front of me and say ones,
people hallucinating the others,
people being played, music I,
I wouldn't be able to
tell you, which was weird,
which tells you two things.
First, this condition is real.
These people are not
making it up. And second,
this goes way beyond the
ordinary experience that
the rest of us have where we
get a song stuck in our head.
These people are getting the full high
Phi experience of listening to music.
Their entire brain is lit up.
The music sounds so convincingly
like real life music.
What are you to think when it suddenly
appears? That's Diana Deutsch,
a psychologist at the University
of California, San Diego,
who's been collecting emails from hundreds
of different people who hallucinate
music. One person described it
in the following way. He said,
imagine that you were at a rock
concert standing right by loudspeaker.
Well, it's louder than that.
At the beginning when I didn't
know what was going to happen,
I thought it was going to take over my
mind. It started interfering with sleep.
It's the Atchison, Topeka and Santa Fe.
[inaudible]
well night. Oh and I, I got mad.
I used to say stop it already.
[inaudible] cut it out. Come on enough.
Enough. Enough. But you never know.
[inaudible]
yes, I never sleep. Yes. That
was the low point. I thought,
I've got to get help for this. At what
point did you bring it up with doctors?
Oh, the doctors completely impotent.
To this day, they rolled their eyes.
When I tell them about it,
one doctor told him that maybe it was
the fillings in his teeth picking up the
radio. Okay. I hoped it was right,
but it wasn't, it continued forever.
Nothing he could do could
make it stop. I don't have any
off button.
It's like there was a jukebox in his
head run by an evil Gremlin and the worst
part, the Gremlin would
mess with the tempo.
Like, uh, okay, uh, [inaudible] that
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, and love the men on the flight.
Daring young man, only the flagging
[inaudible] Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah. That's the worst.
When that started to happen,
I really was getting close to panic as
I have the feeling that it could go at
its rate and I couldn't stop it.
It's like you're on a galloping horse.
The horse is running away with you. Dude.
I once told that to my
daughter. She said, dad,
why don't you just
instead think of the song?
No. And I could control the
tempo and I end instead.
When that was galloping,
I would go, uh, I did, uh,
uh, the
[inaudible]
an immediately up, completely relaxed,
and the Gallup is
completely gone and I
couldn't even let it come
back. And it would
start now being, Oh God,
no, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
and that was no longer ever a problem
of the tempo running away with me.
Okay. So let's just
assume Leo is not crazy.
I never thought I was psychotic.
Never. Never. Because most people,
it turns out with this
condition are not crazy.
There's nothing else wrong with
them. According to Diana Deutsch.
So then the question becomes,
how can a person who is
otherwise sane hallucinate
to such a crazy degree? Well,
in the 60s there was a Polish psychologist
named Jersey Konarski who thought
about this and and he came up with a
simple kind of beautiful idea based on an
assumption that he couldn't prove yet,
which was that between the ears and
the brain, there are some connections.
He thought just a few stray connections
that run backwards brain back to ear,
which would allow sound to run in
reverse. Now, this was just an idea.
He couldn't really test
it, but many years later,
neuroscientists like Tim Griffith
start to poke around in the brain.
They start to explore and what
they find is that he was right.
Yes, daily, right? Do you look at the
pathway between the years and the brain?
Probably about 70% of the fibers
don't actually go up. They go down,
they go the other way. Towards the end,
70% go. 70% go from the
brain to the ears. Yeah.
It's like our ears are literally wired
to hear our brains now. Konarski.
His idea was that normally our ears
wouldn't hear what the brain was saying
because it was too busy. You taking
in all the sounds from the outside,
but what if he thought this
sound from the outside stopped?
Maybe then there would
be a kind of backflow
sound stored in your brain would
start to flow backwards. Now again,
this is just an idea,
but there might be something to this
because it would explain why most of the
people who suffer from
musical hallucinations,
according to Tim Griffith
have one thing in common
by far and away.
The common situation you see it in is
in people who have deafness usually in
middle or later life,
and you have to take his word for it.
Nearly the instant that I went deaf,
I started experiencing round the clock,
24 seven auditory hallucinations.
This is Michael Cora's twin.
He was 36 he lost all of his hearing
and he remembers the moment that it
happened.
He was in the emergency room talking to
a nurse and suddenly the sound started
to go.
It was like going from talking
like this to talking like this,
to talking like this,
to talk like my ears were just draining
out like water draining out of the,
uh, of about, uh, I just king
devore endeavor endeavor.
And at the same time I was dying to hear
a very loud ringing sound in my ears.
It was gradually morphing
prints of sort of formless Erie,
ethereal music,
music of the spheres really.
And you could slowly more
into some version of the Aven Maria
[inaudible].
It was almost as if as a sort
of recompense to being deaf,
I was like plugged into some sort of
deep background Melly and the cosmos.
Now here's the question.
What would happen if Michael
suddenly got his hearing back? Well,
a couple of months later, Michael
got a cochlear implant installed.
This is a little chip.
It's put into his brain,
which promised to return at least
part of his hearing. And he says,
when the doctor's turns on, the
moment he says they turned it on,
it sounds from the world
came rushing in and the music
stopped,
stopped, called just went away
almost instantaneously. Huh?
There you go. Well, but I happen
to know a woman who had a very,
very different experience. What do
you mean is she had the same problem.
She went deaf, she started hearing music.
What's, what kind of music was it? Um,
Hans spirituals, patriotic
songs are her name.
This is actually her real name.
It's Cheryl C's or we're
going to call her sheet.
Wanted the music in her head to stop.
And she'd heard about a patient,
like your friend there who had musical,
whose nation's received a cochlear implant
and her hallucinations disappeared.
So I wanted to do it. So she
did it. She got the implant,
she wakes up on the operating
table and I heard the music.
It was inside me still
there. Just was there.
I can't stop it. Why in the
first case? And they're,
they're kind of the same situation.
They are very much the same.
Why would there be that difference?
I don't know why there is this
difference between those. So I asked, uh,
Dr. Oliver Sacks, who we often
talk to on these questions.
How do you explain the difference
as a physician? Um, you know, um,
one sees patients that you
ask about their symptoms,
they produce their symptoms,
but it is equally important to see the
relation of the symptoms of the disease
to the person themselves,
to their identity.
He's discovered over the years that the
problem is expressed in the patient is
partly a disease. I mean, the person
is sick or in trouble in some way.
At the same time,
the disease is reflecting something
about the person in front of him and sees
interaction and a liaison,
a collusion, the condition,
I don't know what word to use between
the self and a symptom can sometimes it
can come out. So strangely,
for example, there is a,
a patient he has who was a Jewish,
he was a Jewish boy who, who to who?
Them grown up in Hamburg in the 1920s and
1930s and he had been terrified by the
Nazi youth and for some horrible reason
he hallucinated Nazi marching songs.
He was tormented. But on the other hand,
Oliver told me about an old woman he
wants made in a nursing home who was
haunted by lullabies, one
after the other nonstop at sea.
She was an orphan.
Father died before she was born and
her mother before she was five orphaned
alone.
She found the songs in her head
deeply comforting the music and the
hallucinations in fact seem to be a
door into a lost part of childhood.
So then the differences between people
and music floods into their head.
What's going on says Oliver is the
disease and the person they're talking to
each other, the, the self can
be molded by hallucination,
but it can mold them in turn. I
wonder where Leo fits into this. Lulu,
how would you say that Leo self interacts
with his symptoms or vice versa?
Well, uh, he's a psychoanalyst, so
whenever he gets a song stuck in his head,
which is like all the
time, he analyzes it,
he looks for a hidden
meaning and [inaudible]
like, you know the way dreams reveal your
inner life. The same thing with songs.
Leo will tell you that every song
is a message from his subconscious.
Everything has an unconscious
connection, pleasant or unpleasant,
and he's just got to
figure out what it is.
I'm analyzing me like I have a
patient in front of me. Like when I,
I called him up, he had,
Mary had a little lamb stuck in his
head that he told me it was because he'd
been thinking about, Yep.
Passivity of the American people in
following a leader that misleads them.
And everywhere that Mary went,
the lambs was sure to go,
I'm in and the connection is obvious.
Or when he first got home from the
hospital, he always had America.
The beautiful stuck in his head.
And I'm certainly not a raving patriot,
but what this meant was homes,
sweet America to me was home.
It's easy to think that
this is kind of a stretch.
I mean every song has some
very specific meaning for him,
but I dunno,
there was this one time he told me about
where he woke up with a song in his
head.
I stopped going to brush my teeth. I'm
singing along as I go to the bathroom.
This is what it was. It's just a
few years after his wife had died,
my Barney lows over the ocean.
My Bernie lies over the sea.
My Bernie lies over the ocean that
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah. Bring back, bring back,
bring back my Bonnie to me. To me. Yeah.
And um,
I realized when I, I, why
am I singing that song?
And then suddenly I realized it was
our wedding anniversary that week.
That was one of our major
anniversaries. You know,
that song can kill me when I hear it.
Even so he told me that when that
song comes, he doesn't want it to go.
I found that when the song disappeared
that I didn't want it to disappear.
It's now been over a decade of
hallucinating music for Leo.
And he found that at some point the
music switched and went from intruder to
friend
that Duh, Duh, Duh Duh.
Now he looks forward to the song stoves
and still guitars at the company to Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
He finds himself alone
that the the in Monterey.
It's true that one of the things about
being 94 is that when you look at your
telephone address book, the half
of them are not there anymore.
You scratch out the name and
that's not easy. No, no, no.
Just Molly and me and baby
makes three all happy.
And uh, the loo heaven [inaudible]
radio labs. Lulu Miller. Thanks
Lulu. Yep, thanks to Leo.
Leo has a book out about living
with musical hallucinations.
It's called music in the head,
living at the brain mind border.
And so does Michael [inaudible]. He's
the guy with the cochlear implant.
His book is called rebuilt my
journey back to the hearing world.
You can find links to all
of those on our website.
Radio lab.org special thanks to Oliver
Sacks who basically gave us his Rolodex
and we were able to combine all these
people that interview that while thanks to
LRA and Kate Edgar, here's a
system. Absolutely no Robert,
before we go to break, I just don't play
it. One more clip, if you don't mind,
couldn't figure out a place to put it.
From my interview with Diana Deutsch,
I was asking her about
musical hallucinations and
where this stuff comes from,
like where does the music
come from, what triggers it?
And she told me basically,
well, it can be anything.
A striking example was somebody who
wanted very much for her hallucinations to
go and suddenly they did go
away. And so she said, oh great.
This is the sound of
silence. And immediately
song Sandra silence darkness.
Simon and Garfunkel
started at our glued. So
Radiolab will continue in a month.